We know there tend to be supermassive black
holes at the center of galaxies, but the nuances
of galactic evolution are still a mystery.
Now two discoveries may shedding light on
these dark places and the galaxies that form
around them.
In a cloud of molecular gas near the center
of the Milky Way -- so in our own neighbourhood
-- astronomers have found a giant black hole
100,000 times the mass of the Sun.
It’s the second largest supermassive black
hole in our galaxy and the best evidence of
a class of 'intermediate-mass' black holes.
Astronomers have been looking for these because
they might be the key to understanding how
supermassive black holes can get so big.
We know that supermassive black holes formed
early in the Universe’s lifetime, we just
don’t totally know how.
But one theory says that intermediate-mass
black holes might act as seeds for their supermassive
cousins.
Larger, more gravitationally-dominant galaxies
could cannibalize smaller ones that cross
their paths, the larger black hole at the
center pulling the material of the smaller
one into itself.
That means, mid-sized black holes could have
combined to form supermassive structures...right?
The thing is, we also recently found the furthest
supermassive black hole, which means it’s
super old.
With a mass 800 million times greater than
our Sun, it’s enormous.
And did I mention, it’s old?
It grew far larger than expected in the 690
million years after the Big Bang... (which
is the blink of an eye considering the Universe
is more than 13 billion years old).
This relic from the earliest days of the universe
is ALSO devouring all the material near it
meaning it’s a quasar, another indication
it formed early in the Universe’s life.
This black hole is proving to be a window
into a transitional period for the Universe,
but it’s also throwing a bit of a wrench
into how we understand black holes’ formation.
Nothing astronomers have measured can explain
how a supermassive black hole got this big
so long ago.
Something had to have facilitated such rapid
growth, they just don’t know what that SOMETHING
is yet.
It could be that intermediate black holes
hold an answer.But for the moment that remains
a theory.
Astronomers will need more observations and
more data to solidify any link between smaller
black holes and the supermassive ones that
dominate galaxies; not to mention explain
how massive black holes could form so early
in the Universe’s life.
Nevertheless, these discoveries are taking
us one step closer to answering the big question
of how galaxies evolve.
If you liked this video be sure to subscribe
for more science in your daily life, and if
you’re curious about what else is happening
in space, check our playlist here.
The weirdest thing about black holes is that
we, of course, can’t see them.
Astronomers infer their existence from the
material around them.
So cool!